monsieur, je ne comprends pas que j'ai fermé plus d'
affaires que n'importe quel agent ici du FBI,
c'est un agent fédéral au cul serré - aucun
des autres jours, tout comme elle est un
flic dur à cuire de Boston,
laissez-la marcher avec vous, c'est le
meilleur flic de Paul Feig le  directeur des
demoiselles d'honneur le FBI a compétence non
pas là-dedans non ils ne sont pas là-dedans elle
fait elle cherche mes couilles hé si
quelqu'un voit les couilles du capitaine faites-moi
savoir qu'ils sont à peu près aussi gros ils sont
vraiment vraiment minuscule petite fille  couilles si les
petites filles avaient des couilles interviewer eh bien
nous pourrions entrer et les battre avec un
annuaire téléphonique il vous suffit d'être patient
marcher sans réservoir
avoir des tonnes de liens avec le monde de la drogue là-bas
il est tu ne t'intègres pas Je suis un agent fédéral
vraiment parce que tu as l'air de vouloir
installer une table et faire leurs [ __ ] d'
impôts bunnyzon arrête ça il y a Spanx
ils tiennent tout ensemble pourquoi ce qui
va sortir [ __ ]
je ne peux pas te tenir bien une bobine mon
quoi non attends je '  je ne plaisante plus
vraiment je ne peux pas soulever un  la voiture en métal a cassé
sa chute, ouais, secouons-la
Sandra Bullock comme nous le faisons dans la
rue, org ne t'argot pas, c'est comme
regarder une nonne s'embrasser, c'est
inconfortable, nous écouterons le siège auto
bien grand pour toi chérie qui est
que ma mère n'a pas de téléphone portable maintenant
Oh une histoire différente
qui était plutôt géniale